do you want to
play some odds games we could do that
yeah against each other
correct sure let's wait how does it work
because we're about the same level so i
feel we we don't challenge each other
uh i basically uh the the the odds game
gods
just start a position i'm down for that
yeah
yeah we're we're about to find out ooh
okay ah we are we we are playing the
flipped we're playing
flipped i'm black oh i'm black
wait don't don't get made it eric yeah
so this is what i played the other day
uh-huh uh i know you wanna you wanna
mate me with 94. let's play this move
yes i do yeah hikaru and i had like a
nationalist i was the only format that i
could defeat him
in any sort of and then we sped it up
and then yeah i was unsuccessful after
that but
we had some battles so this is
apparently plus six if you go
first but i don't understand really so
yeah
okay let's be let me throw in a novelty
yeah i played i actually played this
last night
and it's so mind-bending
because it looks like the queen is just
hanging on g3 like
the pawns move what
i don't think this is i don't think this
is any good but i just really wanted to
guard my knights
yay
yeah unexpected yeah every night
i mean i think it's a terrible move but
yeah that looks like a like you you
missed an opportunity to make a queen
it's okay uh let's develop it's
it's a gay it's a gay um you want a
queen huh
i would like yeah rather than a knight
oh
stop okay let's make actual queens
why didn't i under promote against i
guess i was just trying to make queens
hikaru had a ton of games he was
attacking me but every time i moved the
piece off the background i would
reinforce and i would get a new queen
also keep in mind it's three minutes so
oh there's no increments
aha no no increment
okay that's good otherwise the chat
would have to
spam yeah yep
okay so i'm up i'm up a queen let's go
no you're not oh
this is so confusing
i like my chances unless i just
blundered
i i i don't i don't have the authority
to tell you
whether you blundered or not uh that's
good
it gives me confidence let's do
this looks aggressive
looks aggressive i don't know if it's
any good but i feel
i feel attacked
just take that
let's take it
my knight comes in handy
you're very short-lived nights
don't insult my night can you insult
something that's dead
probably i mean yes no but it doesn't
have feelings anymore
i suppose it's a little bit too dank for
me applied i don't
ah i think uh you have a better position
thank you i think you
i think you did something correctly and
got
a superior position i'm gonna go here i
managed to
avoid under promoting to a knight
i feel threatened again
that's a good move
but your rook is hanging
let's defend
should i just go for the flag oh my yup
clock
your your yep clock indeed sir
i got i got i got it okay
oh wow oh wow
so with three queens you can you could
triple botezz gambit
you could probably quintuple both has
gambit somehow
that would require five queens
no you just took my queen huh i did
i thought i thought i had something here
but i i
i don't know i just i just don't it's
also possible uh
wow wow now i'm the one low on time
oh no pawns move backwards
no
no don't like this
yeah your pain is my pleasure let's take
this way
oh my god okay keep forgetting about
time
there we go okay i almost forgot about
my time
no that was fun no okay
lesson learned make a queen you got
style points though
that was like promoting tonight was very
stylish
thank you you're welcome thank you
i feel accomplished yeah yeah yeah like
that's that that one that one hurts i'm
not gonna lie
i that one hurt
that one hurt and then i just got a
notification that uh
my mobile provider i withdrew money from
my bank
to auto pay my bill so i just lost the
game i lost money
bad at least your bill is paid
i do suppose that is wow all right
do you think what do you think will
happen here
i don't know i even know what opening to
play
i guess i'll play a sicilian
hmm can you play can you play sicilian
in this
i guess you can i'm gonna play the grand
prix attack of the sicilian okay
and play the wow all right okay
all right oh now you get a knife okay i
mean
wow wow you won connect four but this is
a fork
yeah i was just assuming that i could
like zero use
my man is just unafraid he just he don't
care
all
alright
okay i feel like i'm about to get alpha
zero
but i have a very important very nice
defensive resource
this knight will be saved by my g pawn
yes and then if i take and peasant
[Music]
mr rosen defends his position
terrible but it's okay at least your
night is out of the game
isn't that the whole point of alpha's
zero technique it's like
yeah you don't care about material you
just care about
like beating stockfish
so you can't move your knight anymore
wow
but i can move my other knight my many
other nights
i feel like this would be very difficult
to do blindfold
oh yeah there's so many nights you have
to keep track of like which one moves
which square
oh you won connect four again did i oh
yeah yeah
no me i'm a beast all right let's
let's attack why
why not
ha
boom boom boom take
there no
what is this
what is this
thought i thought i was making some
progress it's not gonna lie
still gonna trap your knife on the edge
of the board
so there's a difference between being
trapped and just being stuck
for now i'm just stuck i still have life
there's a difference i'm going to try
and trap your king
good luck thanks
all right here we go what oh really
yeah wow
so that's complicated
let's be let's be civil
are you considering king f4 on i guess
not no no no king f4 would be a
would be aesthetic but uh
yeah but you have knight f3 which is
stupid but i have i have a fork
wow wow
okay knights are being traded i guess
yeah okay i gotta get i gotta get more
more nice to the party here
man chad is still petting hikaru
well obviously and his game is uh is not
live but it's it's it's loaded
so we will go there in a second um
no worries we'll be there every night is
is
is coming to play now here we go uh
i miss being up a pawn can you not
wow some some
extravagant tacticals okay i'm going to
sack the knights
oh no my knight
what are you what are you doing i i have
no idea if this is
working but feel free to think for about
30 more seconds
i'm gonna take it i don't believe you
okay
where's your mate where is my mates
where is your mate good question i don't
wanna
wait where where's my mate
always undeveloped
am i actually gonna get am i gonna get
the eric rosen treatment here
like when you when you
f6 bam
oh my god i got made a ggo
i felt so good that was so nice oh i i i
i didn't anytime you say
oh no my piece i guess you just it can't
be taken
i guess it was just yeah except actually
i'm not sure i just wanted to make you
second guess yourself
but wow that was a pretty i mean you
kind of went in
deep there it it's hard to get out